ja dann begrüßte sie zur letzten sitzung
in diesem semester in der wir uns sehr
anspruchsvolle themen vorgesetzt haben
nämlich zuallererst nochmal einen
philosophen mit einem sehr netten barth
nämlich mit der wii louis blues aus
princeton und wenn sie david luiz hören
da müssen sie immer sofort denken an
mögliche welten
es ist ganz wichtig eine mögliche welt
aber was ist denn der mögliche bild
haben sie eine idee was ist in alle
möglichen will bei welchem philosoph
kommt die mögliche welt zum ersten mal
diese art vor mehr formuliert so eine
idee einen möglichen welt und das ist
eine mögliche welt haben sie eine idee
genau da denke ich auch leibnitz also
einen was ist dann eine mögliche welt
haben sie eine idee was wie könnte man
die beschreiben oder anders gefragt was
ist eine unmögliche welt das wäre eine
mögliche welle gegensatz zu seinen
möglichen welt
also ja
er hat die frage wäre was war ein
widerspruch also logisch widersprüche wo
vielleicht logische widersprüche möglich
wären
oder wo logische widersprüche vorkämen
wo zwei plus zwei gleich fünf ist oder
wo irgendwie die wahrheit' bedingungen
von konditionellen anders aussehen als
wir es in den letzten sitzung gesprochen
hatten
es ist nicht so ganz klar eine mögliche
welt hingegen ist eben eine welt die
nicht logisch widersprüchlich ist als
eine mögliche welt die auf tatsachen
verhalten wie sie leibnitz nennen würde
besteht die also kontingent sind also
eine mögliche welt wäre auch eine wo der
david luiz kein bart ererbte oder
wäre dann noch david luiz es ist gute
frage
also wo vielleicht dieser tisch ist hier
eine ein irgendwie ein logo auf der
mitte hat ja also es ist irgendwie
logisch möglich aber es ist eine ganz
komplizierte geschichte wenn man da ein
bisschen näher und geht in diese
philosophin diese metaphysik möglicher
welt und sehr schnell sehr kompliziert
und wir haben jetzt und sich ein paar
leitfragen überlegt nämlich wie
interpretiert dieser herr mit diesen
mitteln baut die kausalität relation im
rahmen seiner theorie möglicher welten
und dann ganz besonders interessant wird
die zweite frage sein wie interpretiert
louis die kausalität relation im rahmen
seiner contra faktischen analyse also
contra faktisch heißt eben wenn das
nicht gewesen wäre dann wäre auch das
nicht gewesen
also das war so ein konditionell was
aber eben von einer anderen anderen
perspektive das ganze betrachtet und wir
haben in der letzten sitzung damit schon
kurz begonnen und mit diesem thema und
werden da jetzt heute weiter anknüpfen
und es wird jetzt mal wieder um david
healy umgehen der für alle angelsachsen
aber auch für viele kontinentaleuropäer
der anknüpfungspunkt für jede theorie
von kausalität ist das war deswegen wie
sie alle wissen weil er eben diese
relation sehr problematisiert hat man
kann sagen der widum hat so eine
logische und eine systemische kritiker
analyse des qualitäts begriffs gegeben
sie wissen alle er ist wird zu den
empirischen gezählt und er hat zuerst
mal gezeigt dass wir diese notwendigkeit
des übergangs eine ursache zu einer
wirkung das wird die nicht empirisch
wahrnehmen können
das eben der übergang von ursache und
wirkung eine notwendigkeit enthält die
was sich uns nicht sinnes mäßig
darstellt das heißt wir müssen sie
irgendwo anders her bekommen der
immanuel kant hatte dann daraus
geschlossen dass diese notwendigkeit
eben aus unserer vernunft kommt aus
unserem verstand genau genommen und
jedenfalls ist das die empirische sicht
und es gibt eben noch eine logische
sicht die man david hume zu schreiben
kann dass es dann eher so eine
formulierung der kausalität als regula
ried also von typen und vorkommnissen
all das ist eben die selben vorkommnisse
theater eben dieselben also vorkommnisse
derart erzeugen
eine regelmäßigkeit und jetzt sagt david
luiz ganz zu beginn jung definierte die
kausalität gleich zweimal er schrieb wir
können eine ursache definieren als ein
objekt auf das ein anderes volk bei
allen objekten die den ersten ähnlich
sind objekte folgen die den zweiten
ähnlich sind welche qualität er wird
jetzt hier noch mal formuliert wie nennt
man die die erste das ist also die
reguläre these der kausalität also
deswegen mache ich selbst schreibe
diesmal groß also weil das eben dann bei
jetzt hier nicht erst mal nicht klar ist
ob jetzt dieses dieser pfeil einmal eine
materiale implikation ist wir haben das
letzte mal darüber diskutiert sie kennen
alle wenn sie mal bei wikipedia schauen
ich bin der meinung man sollte das nicht
zitieren in hausarbeiten aber man kann
sich sehr gut darüber informieren wenn
sie mal schauen die paradoxien der
materialen implikationen gibt es einen
eigenen wikipedia eintrag es
hochinteressant weil eben für bestimmte
war heizwert verteilung dieses
konditionen als das ganze war ist und
wir intuitiv nicht sagen würden dass es
wahr ist
das kommt daher dass wir immer das
material die materielle implikation
immer als kausalität redaktion
interpretieren was ja gar nicht ist das
ist ja gar kein da ist ja gar keine
notwendigkeit hier enthalten also im
sinne des das verursachen keine
produktion kann hervorbringen das ist
einfach nur eine relation die eben
stimmt geordnet ist dass die regular
riet er ihr und jetzt sagt er folgendes
und das ist ein ganz ganz strittiger
punkt da haben sie zu recht darauf
hingewiesen letzten sitzung oder mit
anderen worten hätte dass die erste
obliegt es nicht gegeben dann hätte das
zweite nie existiert und das kann man
jetzt blieben so das muss man so
formalisieren also auf dieser ebene
hätte wäre angewiesen
und dann wäre wenig gewesen das ist
jetzt eine contra faktische formulierung
und jetzt kann man da lange darüber sind
unterhalten sie haben zu recht darauf
hingewiesen wenn man das mit anderen
worten die frage ist jetzt wer ist das
verstehen mit anderen worten ist das mit
anderen worten auf was bezieht sich das
mit anderen worten bezieht das mit
anderen worten auf die erste
bestimmung von kausalität als ist dass
das in allen b in anderen worten dann
wäre sicherlich falsch oder ist dieses
mit anderen worten zu beziehen
auf wir können eine ursache definieren
wir können sie auf zwei weisen
definieren kausalität
also wir haben zwei
interpretationsmöglichkeiten von
qualität und nicht das ist nicht die
unter die andere sicht von dieser regula
ried theorie sondern von kausalität und
dann wenn man eben so macht dann kann
man sagen okay er hat zwei intuitionen
hier ein bisschen generalisiert und
gesagt klar
schauen sie mal wie man aber zurück
aufgaben dieses bedingung von mickey
mickey sagt ja dass kausal relevante
element element die ursache das ist die
ist nicht hinreichend
er soll sie ist eben teil einer
hinreichende bedingung aber für diese
eben notwendig dann ja und diese
formulierung die zeigt an dass die
ursache immer eine art von notwendigkeit
besitzt wenn sie an die lust bedingungen
wenn dieses entscheidende moment nicht
gewesen wäre dann wäre es nicht zum
brand gekommen
ja und diese formulierung die zeigt er
an die gesamtsituation von dieser
bedingung das sagen mit den
randbedingungen zusammen das ganze dann
bewirkt wurde
also ich denke mit diesen zwei
formulierungen haben wir eigentlich die
infos bedingungen bisschen eingeholt
also sind zwei aspekte dieser komplexen
kausalität relation oder was würden sie
sagen ja
ich meine dass
nichts machen das ist das erste break
nach sich ziehen muss der sehe ich
keinen unterschied zwischen dem
kontrollrat ischen konditionalität eifer
außerdem hat er ein
das ist eine einig ein guter guter punkt
und da wird natürlich eine gewisse
notwendigkeit behauptet aber die
notwendigkeit wird irgendwie über die
theorie der möglichen welten realisiert
und das wollen wir ja heute ich hatte ja
auch vorhin gesagt das ist eine ganz
komplizierte geschichte die theorie der
möglichen welten und also dieses sei im
recht da ist so eine notwendigkeit drin
aber halt eine notwendigkeit über
möglichkeiten über möglichkeit also es
gibt hier sagen ein einspiel von
modalitäten
das ist der punkt hier wird die
modalitäten miteinander verschränkt und
das wollen wir jetzt heute eben genauer
uns nochmal anschauen wie diese
modalitäten hier im einzelnen
verschränkt sind ja
was was ähnlich
das stelle
gleich genau also das ist eben diese
regularien dass man eben vom selben typ
also dass man eben objekte
klassifizieren kann dass man also nicht
nur von singulären ereignissen spricht
von also von nicht mehr wiederkehrenden
ereignissen sondern dass man sagen kann
das volk eingesetzt und das sich eben
bestimmte ereignisse unter ein gesetz
subsumieren kann setzt voraus dass es
sich ähnlich sind sonst könnte müsste
ich könnte ich keine generellen
kausalität aussagen formulieren bin ich
für jede
ja
schön kleine chance oder wasser
auskommen
noch immer ein bisschen anders aus es
ist außerdem die mit der post gekommen
ist
ach so das heißt einen echten machen
es ist derselbe typus derselbe typ ist
und der wird eben instanziert von
vorkommnissen die natürlich als
vorkommnisse als individuen nie
identisch miteinander sind das ist da
sondern sie sind eben nur dadurch
identische dass sie dem selben typ zu
gehören
ganz genau
genau
ja genau weil wenn sie nur den virus
also dass wir uns alleine ansehen dann
wird das nie dasselbe sein weil es immer
um ein paar moleküle irgendwie abweicht
europa tue ich weiß nicht was es geht
einfach darum dass wir hier so eine
gewisse ordnung bekommen und david hume
hatte ja eigentlich gesagt das war also
die pointe bei david hume im extremen
sinne dass wir eigentlich gar keine
typen bilden können als es gibt
verschiedene lesarten von der witterung
und die radikale lesart die ist dann
eigentlich so wir haben immer nur diese
individuellen ereignisse und typen typen
nehmen wir nicht wahr
wir haben keine wahrnehmung von
treppenstufen sind volker sind
ergebnisse von verschlüssen dass wir
eben abstraktionen will aber ein typus
zum beispiel plattform dach der wir
nehmen den typus direkt war also wir
haben die idee die haben wir mal
wahrgenommen oder geschaut natürlich
nicht empirisch sind individuell vor
unsere geburt über himmlische nord damit
die mal geschaut und weil wir sie vor
unserer geburt geschaut haben können wir
uns wieder daran erinnern
das heißt wenn wir ein konkretes
individuelles objekt als solches
erkennen das ist ein vorkommnis des typs
baum dann erkennen wir eigentlich wieder
erinnern wir uns wieder das ist da die
idee des baumes gibt und dass dieses
konkrete dinge darunter fällt und das
ist natürlich wird in der neuzeit nicht
mehr so gesehen sind da wird er
abstraktion theorie behauptet und da
wird dann eben ein typus konstruiert in
theley gebe und da
neben jung wie gesagt den typus nehmen
wir nicht wahr empirisch das ist ein
produkt unseres schlosses und der sei
eine riesengeschichte jetzt hier wie
gesagt wir können ebenso als ich mal
wieder da sagt er erfasst hier
eigentlich zwei intuitionen der der eos
bedingungen nämlich einmal so ein moment
der das hinreichenden das natürlich mit
dem ganzen umgebungsbedingungen zusammen
und hier wird die intuition der
notwendigkeit eingefangen aber es gibt
eben noch war zusätzlicher punkt dieses
was wäre wenn dieses diese spielerei
sozusagen diese spielereien der
möglichkeiten da kommen noch die theorie
der möglichen welten ein
und das ist eben deswegen contra
faktisch weil eben hier die möglichen
welten ins spiel kommen und jetzt wollen
wir mal weiter lesen nämlich er sagt
jetzt folgendes gefolgsleute von jungs
erste definition beherrschen immer noch
die philosophie der kausalität für sie
ist eine kausale abfolge eine folge die
einen konkreten fall eine regelmäßigkeit
darstellt natürlich gab es
verbesserungen so versucht man heute
zwischen wesentlichen regelmäßigkeiten
den kausal gesetzen und bloß zufälligen
regelmäßig aufeinander folgen zu
unterscheiden
ursachen und wirkung werden aufgrund der
kennzeichnung diese erfüllen und nicht
aufgrund der gesamt ähnlichkeit unter
den begriff der regelmäßigkeit
subsumiert außerdem darf eine ursache
nur einen notwendigen teil der situation
ausmachen nicht aber die gesamtsituation
auf die in eine wirkung gemäss angesetzt
folgt das ist praktisch die inus
bedingung das ist eben nur einen
norwegen teil aus markt in heutigen
regelmäßigkeit analysen wird eine
ursache grob definiert als ein
beliebiges element einer beliebigen
minimalen menge bestehende umstand die
unter voraussetzung der gesetze sammeln
hinreichend firma sind
existenz der wirkung sind also hier hat
fand ich noch mal sehr interessant dass
er hier sagte situation sehen sich wir
hatten uns häufig überlegt gedanken
gemacht und theologie er sagt es nicht
dass ursachen situationen sind aber
ursachen sind teile oder elemente einer
situation nämlich einer mit den ursachen
zusammen mit der ursache
zusammengenommen notwendigen situation
die daneben das ereignis seien
hinreichend martin reicht ist hat die
zusammen hinreichend sind für das
ereignis das scheint ihr so die
märkische - bedingung zu sein
jetzt frage ich mal zurück würden sie
sagen dass megi eine regelmäßigkeit
theorie der kausalität behauptet hat
das ist ja bei mac i kommt ja glaube ich
regelmäßigkeit gar nicht so vor
also er überhaupt spricht da nicht so
sehr darüber aber ich denke schon dass
das so ein bisschen diese auch bei
märklin bis in diese richtung der
regelmäßigkeit analyse geht jetzt ist
hier eben noch folgendes jetzt ist hier
eben noch ein weiterer punkt und zwar
kommt jetzt hier noch der begriff des
gesetzes ins spiel ins spiel
hier hatten sie bei mac i irgendwas über
gesetze gelesen hatte gästen gesetzes
begriff behandelt ich mag mich nicht
mehr zu erinnern dass er aufgesetzt
eingegangen also das könnte man auch
normale mecki zurückfragen mecki musste
nicht implizit noch gewisse gesetze als
gültig ansätzen ja vielleicht die
naturgesetze oder irgendetwas anderes
das eben eine bedingung überhaupt
funktioniert wenn du eine regelmäßigkeit
analyse hast als unter denselben
bedingungen wird das eben immer wieder
eintreten könnte man auch noch zurück
fragen weil das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt die sie gesetze die dem ganzen der
ganzen regula ried zugrunde liegen
müssen
es genügt ja nicht einfach immer nur
diese abfolge beobachtet zu haben sagt
david jung sondern wir müssen sie ja und
theologisch behaupten können und das
setzt natürlich voraus dass da
irgendwelche gesetze noch am werke sind
ja
[Musik]
genau
also es halt dabei spricht meines
wissens nicht so sehr über gesetze
mitglieder müssen meine texte mal
daraufhin lesen aber das findet dort
keine verwendung
also mir scheint dass er hier mekies
theorie so ein bisschen beschreibt die
story ist sowieso eine der
einflussreichsten qualitäts theorien die
es gibt und sie fragen zu recht warum
sollen wir dann hier noch mit seiner
grund hektisch analyse kommen das ist
doch alles in mekies theorie schon
gesagt es ist richtig aber eben unter
es kommt eben doch so diese mögliche
welt mitspielen wir müssen uns wirklich
fragen was ist damit gewonnen was ist
damit für unser verständnis von qualität
gewonnen wenn wir kausalität contra
faktisch analysieren und nicht nur im
sinne der notwendigen bedingungen
angeben also die frage ist halt genau
bitte hier
das ist doch ne schwierige situation
kostet sortieren was muss ich jetzt
alles eigentlich angucken das
bedingungen wie sie scheinen
vorsichtig zu sein das organ bedingungen
die zu kriegen
es ist schon schwierig ist genau zu
erfassen
dieser von dem von dem feld
das ganze ist zwar auch diese war
ebenfalls schwierigkeiten bank austria
und csu konnten
dessen guter punkt also auf ihre frage
geantwortet
wir betrachten eben nur ein bestimmtes
element dieser menge die
zusammengenommen eben hinreichend ist
für gm und schauen dann was wäre wenn
jetzt eben dieses ein element gibt dass
die ursache ist nicht wäre dann brauchen
wir eben wie sie richtig sagen gar nicht
diese anderen bedingungen noch
aufzuklären also wie sieht es jetzt aus
mit der sprinkleranlage und wie sieht's
aus mit dem brennbaren element material
und so weiter sondern wir sagen wir
definieren kausalität einfach nur was
wäre wenn das nicht gewesen wäre dieses
entscheidende element
jetzt kann man sich natürlich genau und
jetzt kann man sich natürlich noch
fragen wie ist es jetzt mit diesem
praktisch mit der mit dem brennbaren
materials könnte man da dann nicht wie
wäre es da mit dem brennbarem material
dann würde man ja dann das nicht so
formulieren wenn das brennbare material
nicht gewesen wäre dann wäre der hand
nicht gewesen hat deshalb die frage man
könnte das jetzt prima partie auch so
formulieren aber es würde dann
letztendlich nicht die kausalität
betreffen das chaos relevante ereignisse
genauso ist notwendig ja richtig das ist
richtig also man hätte jetzt hier noch
nicht differenziert zwischen dem den
elementen die eben wirklich not die
notwendig sind oder die eben den
ursachen sind und den anderen ich meine
mecki sagt er
diese anderen randbedingungen die sind
ja jetzt nicht eigentlich im stricken
sinne notwendig zu zu nennen
nur die ursache ist ja eigentlich
notwendig also wenn wir da mackey in
dieser dieser entität jetzt wenn wir als
die folgen und sagen das ist das einzige
notwendigen moment dann dann kann man
wirklich sagen dann machen wir daraus
einfach die kontrolle faktisch analyse
weil dann blenden wir das andere aus
dann konzentrieren uns darauf aber hier
ist jetzt der folgende punkt mecki louis
möchte gar keine reguläre theorie
vertreten als er möchte gar nicht
kausalität im sinne der regionalität
analysieren er möchte ist ein
alternativvorschlag bringen und das ist
dann diese kontrakte sind das jetzt nur
die eine tradition oder eine
herangehensweise an kausalität aber
jetzt genau also es bleibt sagt er jetzt
es bleibt abzuwarten ob es irgendeine
regelmäßigkeit analyse gelingen wird
echte ursachen von wirkungen ep
phänomenen und abgeschalteten möglichen
ursachen ausgeschalteten ist
unterscheiden ohne dabei noch schlimmere
probleme schlimmeren problemen zum opfer
zu fallen ohne weitere apps zu
konstruieren und ohne von der grundidee
abzukommen kausalität sei auf
regelmäßigkeit zurückzuführen ich habe
keinen beweis dafür dass die
regelmäßigkeit analyse nicht zu retten
ist es fehlt mir hier auch der platz um
die schon versuchten ausbesserung zu
diskutieren möge deshalb die
feststellung genug
dass die aussichten auf eine
erfolgreiche ausbesserung gering sind
und dass es an der zeit ist aufzugeben
und etwas anderes zu versuchen als er
möchte jetzt hier die regular ried terry
aufgeben so zu sagen möchte sie jetzt
mainseite lassen er möchte jetzt mal
eine andere theorie versuchen und dafür
ist auch louis recht berühmt geworden
also für diese contra faktisch eine
qualitätsanalyse das ist jetzt ein punkt
als er möchte jetzt einen weiteren tipp
von kausalität theorien ins spiel
bringen wir haben jetzt sehr
verschiedene typen jetzt schon
kennengelernt also wir haben die regular
wie theorie die eben auf david hume
zurückgeht von diesen gleichartigen
ereignissen auch die das in einer
regelmäßigkeit nach gesetzen nach
gesetzen auch erfolgt dann haben wir
diese ins bedingung das ist könnte man
sagen vielleicht eine modifizierte
reform der regionalität theorie müsste
man sich fragen also wo halt hier eben
dieses alte cds noch mal weiter
analysiert wird in randbedingungen und
in das notwendige moment der
ursächlichkeit und jetzt haben wir hier
noch eine dritte theorie die wir die
contra faktische analyse der qualität
nennen könnten also möchte jetzt mal was
anderes versuchen also müssen wir
schauen ob es ihm gelingt nach einer
lohnenden alternative muss man nicht
lange suchen jungs alternativ
formulierung also oder mit anderen
worten das wenn das erste nicht gewesen
wird das festival hätte ist die ursache
nicht gegeben hätte es die hätte die
wirkung nicht existiert ist nämlich
keine bloße umformulierung seine ersten
definition sie schlägt etwas ganz
anderes vor nämlich eine contra
faktische analyse der kausalität dieses
mit anderen worten bezieht sich nicht
auf die regular readers these sind auf
die qualitäts definition wir können
qualität auch mit anderen worten
noch dann ist hier so kann man jetzt jun
retten
ob das jung tatsächlich so gemeint hat
weiß ich nicht
sie haben bestimmt recht dass man auch
prima fazit doch sagen müsste er hat
hier einfach logischen fehlern gar dass
der ist man aber wenn man eben besonders
freundlich ist das principle of charity
das prinzip der hermeneutischen
freundlichkeit dass man das ganz hoch
hält dann müsste man eben sagen nein er
hat er nur zwei intuitionen der
kausalität versucht zu fassen
die kausalität mit anderen worten so
bestimmen und jetzt geht es also um
diese contra faktisch analyse und contra
faktisch heißt wie es geht jetzt nicht
um diese reale wirkliche welt es geht um
eine mögliche welt in der eben das nicht
gewesen wäre und was wäre dann gewesen
die frage ist halt ob es ohne analyse
von kausalität uns wirklich dieses
phänomen verständlicher werden lässt das
ist einfach die frage die wir uns jetzt
hier stellen müssen dieser vorschlag
einer konto faktischen analyse der
kausalität auf 204 wurde bis jetzt nicht
richtig auch nicht recht aufgegriffen
wir wissen zwar das korsett irgendetwas
mit contra faktischen kondition ahlen zu
tun hat denn wir stellen uns eine
ursache ist etwas vor das einen
unterschied bewirkt und zwar ein
unterschied zu dem was ohne die ursache
passiert wäre
denken sie an die inus bedingung denken
sie an diesen kurzschluss der
kurzschluss macht einen großen
unterschied aus
bei den jungen
genau möchte ist hier nur analysieren er
möchte eben dieses phänomen hat etwas
angesetzt wird was wirksam ist einfach
bestimmen er möchte das modellieren wie
es wie wir es eben am besten verstehen
können also wir können ebenso versuchen
zu modellieren sowie sagen es gibt ein
regula riet den agb oder eben wir sagen
wenn ebendies entscheidende moment nicht
gewesen wäre dann wäre eben das nicht
passiert wir reden über dasselbe
phänomen eben auf zwei verschiedenen aus
zwei verschiedenen perspektiven
wir reden einmal im sinne der
wirklichkeit oder der konsequenz müsste
man sagen der konsequenz und einmal
reden wir über kausalität leben im sinne
der möglichkeit das ist eine selbe
phänomen einmal eben modal einmal modal
gewendet und einmal also das ist ja auch
also diese kontrakte analyse setzt ja
auch so eine art konsequenz voraus aber
sie bringt eben noch die modalitäten
drei modelle analyse die eben im ersten
fall so nicht nicht gegeben ist also ich
denke das zweite mal gesetzt wir haben
da so ein soziales phänomen
wir wollen das jetzt aber versuchen
begrifflich oder logisch zu modellieren
das ist jetzt glaube ich die spannende
frage
es macht einen unterschied und das sehen
wir bei der eos bedingung wenn wir eben
in der enns bedingungen im anti cds
jetzt dieses diese diesen kurzschluss
nicht haben wenn das nicht gewesen wäre
dann wäre eben etwas ganz anders
herausgekommen wäre es ganz anderes
passiert hätte es zur lag gegeben hätte
es auch ihre wirkung zumindest einige
und im normalfall nicht gegeben
also die wirkung ist eben im falle des
kurzschlusses der haus brandner
aber es ist eine sache diese platten
dauernd wiederholen und eine andere
sache auf ihnen eine analyse passieren
zu lassen also miteinander
gemüse geben das schien sich bis jetzt
nicht zu lohnen
wir wissen nur zu gut dass contra
faktische kondition aale ein schwieriges
gebiet darstellen weshalb es nicht den
anschein hatte als sehr viel dazu
gewonnen wenn man sie zur analyse der
kausalität oder andere dinge heran züge
da ein besseres verständnis der contra
faktischen konditionen noch groß stand
hatten wir auch keine mittel um gegen
scheinbare gegenbeispiele zu einer
contra faktischen analyse erfolgreich
sondern zu argumentieren
gegen einen scheinbar und gegen
scheinbare gegenbeispiel
ja es gibt es einfach hier probleme mit
dieser konter faktischen analyse und
david luiz meint er könne jetzt diese
ganzen probleme lösen die eben mit einer
solchen interpretation einhergehen ich
meine jedoch dass die kontroll
faktischen konditionelle kein
schwieriges gebiet bleiben müssen
es sei denn wir klammern uns an falsche
vorgefasste meinungen darüber was es
heißt sie verstehen darf denn eine art
ein adäquates verständnis kein bezug auf
nicht aktualisierte möglichkeiten nehmen
und er setzt die entscheidende frage
also darf denn nicht um etwas über die
wirklichkeit zu sagen auch eine
möglichkeit mit einbezogen werden müssen
dabei scharf abgegrenzte wahrheit'
bedingungen festgelegt werden müssen
contra faktische kontrolle statt an
entsprechende gesetze angekoppelt werden
wenn ja müssen wir allerdings noch lange
auf ein adäquates verständnis werden
umso schlimmer für derartige maßstäbe
von adäquatheit warum sollten wir denn
die contra faktischen konditionelle
nicht als das nehmen was sie zu sein
scheinen als aussagen über mögliche
alternativ situationen die etwas vage
spezifiziert sind und in dem es besteht
und gesetzen in denen die bestehenden
gesetze weiterhin gelten oder auch nicht
gelten mögen es gibt zurzeit mehrere
solcher behandlung von contra faktischen
konditionelle die sich nur in details
unterscheiden wenn sie korrekt sind dann
hat man solide grundlage für analysen
die sich konträr faktischer art
konditionelle bedienen
also durch die entscheidende frage ist
jetzt hier darf denn hier dritte zeile
darf denn ein adäquates verständnis kein
bezug auf nicht aktualisierte
möglichkeiten nehmen er geht jetzt
einfach von den möglichkeiten aus er
sagt es gibt mögliche welten und manche
der möglichen welten sind eben
aktualisiert sie sind nicht nur denkbar
sind auch wirklich nicht nur möglich
sondern wirklich und manche eben nicht
das ist eben eine ganz andere welt sich
natürlich kann man jetzt zu recht sagen
wir sollten doch das prinzip der
ontologischen sparsamkeit waren wir
sollten zu wenige welten oder so wenig
es annehmen wie nur möglich gelernt
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen ist
eine mögliche welt überhaupt eine
ontologische existierende welt also
nehmen wir wenn wir machen lassen wir
uns wenn wir mögliche wilden auf
annehmen überhaupt konto logisch etwas
zusätzlich auf ist denn eine mögliche
welt eine existierende welt das ist die
spannende frage
und es ist nicht nur eine logische
option
ja ich glaub es nicht aber also dem
multi wersen und so das ist tatsächlich
ein ökologisches problem das ist das ist
ein gravierendes metaphysisches problem
ich glaube aber hier die rede von
möglichen welten ist so stark logisch
orientiert dass sie ontologisch uns
nicht so viel probleme macht das ist
also die frage wirklich wie eine
mögliche welt zu verstehen ist ist eine
spannende frage
ich glaube wir müssen sie nicht so stark
ökologisch verstehen aber wir wollen
jetzt einfach mal weiter lesen also dass
also die frage wie gesagt es geht also
um modalitäten wir betrachten die welt
betrachten die welt unter dem
gesichtspunkt der möglichkeit die selbe
welt eigentlich unter dem gesichtspunkt
der möglichkeit also die rede von
möglichen welten ist eigentlich ein
bisschen irreführend weil wenn man dann
gleich nebenan so multiversum denkt es
sind einfach nur es dieselbe welt in
einen anderen modus eine andere
modalität könnte man sagen denke dass
das besser wird besatzung verständnis
beiträgt
schließt man einfach mal weiter in
diesem aufsatz und das ist jetzt eben
wieder ein typisch angelsächsisches
paper
die haben nur 20 seiten und die sagen
gleich am anfang worum es den geht das
ist eben diese tradition wenn sie zb
schelling lesen meine zeit seminar haben
wir schelling gelesen da weiß man nach
300 zeit noch nicht weil sie eigentlich
möchte und das werk ist auch noch 300
seiten gar nichts ende weil es gibt da
noch fünf verschiedene fassungen und es
ist noch fragment geblieben damit will
ich nicht sagen dass schelling kein
guter film software aber ich will damit
nur auf die verschiedenen traditionen
hinweisen das ist eben jetzt einer der
angelsächsische schule der sagt eben
gleich in diesem aufsatz werde ich eine
contra faktischen analyse die von jungs
zweiter definition nicht also sehr
abweicht ist ein paar arten von
kausalität durchführen ich werde dann zu
zeigen versuchen wir es mit dieser
sind echte ursachen von wirkungen und
ausgeschalteten möglichen ursachen
unterscheiden jetzt müssen noch die
happy phänomene sind also den männern
also nicht
ja es geht in die richtung ja
gleichzeitig mit den ursachen
es könnte sogar auch zeitlich darauf
folgen
vielleicht aber ein wichtiger punkt ist
noch das sei jetzt ep phänomen der
selbst ist nicht eine mögliche ursache
mir das selbst ist nicht mehr causa
relevant als ep phänomen haben keine
kausalen relevanz wie es eben bei
kausalketten der fall ist also ein epi
phänomen ist kein mögliches glied einer
kausalkette sonst ein endprodukt gehört
das ganze dann auch da selbst ist ein
abfallprodukt sozusagen also häufig wird
mancher wird über selbstbewusstsein
zugesprochen
die ich glaube nicht dass es richtig ist
aber manche theoretikerin und
theoretiker sagen das selbstbewusstsein
ein epi phänomen von neuronalen vorgänge
ist so von anorganischen vorgängen
selbstbewusstsein ist etwas was bloß
reagiert wichtiger begriff ist auch noch
ergänzt was bloß auftritt so plötzlich
wenn eben genug neuronen verschaltet
sind
das problem was man bei so einer ep
phänomenalen sicht auf selbstbewusstsein
bekommt ist folgendes wir glauben doch
dass wir durch gedanken und überlegungen
etwas verursachen können dass wir durch
unser selbstbewusstsein casale
unterschied in der welt bewirken können
und das würde voraussetzen dass wir eben
dass ein phänomen das täten was es eben
per definition nicht kann also wir
glauben eben an mentale verursachung und
es die apple phänomenologische analyse
des selbstbewusstseins steht einem
gewissen spannungsverhältnis zur
mentalen verursachen
sonst müsste man sagen nicht dass
metalle verursacht wird was sind eben
die neuronalen vorgänge oder die
physikalischen ereignissen zum gehirn
verursachen etwas und das ist natürlich
sehr reduktionistischen analyse kann man
machen aber ich glaube dann wird das
ganze nicht mehr verständlich weil wir
haben ja gewiss
ziele wir haben gewisse zwecke und
zwecke und ziele naturalistisch zu
modellieren ist ziemlich schwierig kann
versuchen aber es ist schwieriger als ep
phänomene sind eben keine richtigen
wirkungen die dann ihrerseits wieder
ursachen sein könnten für weitere
ereignisse und das möchte eben
ausschließen von wirklichen wirkungen
wirklich bewegt sind ok um eine
vorgehensweise in meine vorgehensweise
wird in mindestens vier punkten
unvollständig seien um unklarheiten zu
vermeiden soll zunächst gesagt werden
was alles außer acht gelassen wird als
er lässt jetzt einiges außer acht
erstens ich werde mich auf kausalität
zwischen ereignissen ereignissen
umgangssprachlichen sind es weiters
gebraucht beschränken also auf blitze
schlachten unterhaltung stöße
spaziergänge todesfälle
zwischenlandungen stürze küsse und
ähnliches das heißt nicht dass
ereignisse die einzigen dinge sind die
etwas verursachen können beziehungsweise
besucht verursacht werden können ich
besitze aber keine vollständige liste
der andere dinge und keine kann passen
oberbegriff mit dem sie alle zu erfassen
wären
das ist wieder unsere spannende frage
nach der ontologie von ursachen was für
arten von dingen sind den ursachen haben
da einige möglichen kandidaten gab dann
gesagt prozesse werden sich prozesse er
nicht weil prozess in sich schon kausal
strukturiert sind prozessen kleine
kausale übergänge also prozesse nicht
ereignis ist ein ganz klassischer punkt
dann könnte man sagen tatsache oder ein
sachverhalt wurde man könne sagen die
situation habe bei situationen sehen sie
situationen werden lassen sich
analysieren wie dieses bedingungen als
situationen haben eben dann sind größere
bereiche in denen eben das eigentlich
ursächliche nur ein element ist wie zum
beispiel der kabelbrand in dieser
situation des brennbaren materials
drumherum und der fehlende sprint anlage
[Musik]
sie gleich dazu
sie wollen gleich was dazu sagen weil ja
genau richtig
genau also eine schlacht ist ein prozess
eine schlacht ist eine situation auch am
prozess auf jeden fall ein blitz ist
eher sowas geld was in stent eines
einsturz auch spaziergang
das ist eine bedingung genau das ist das
eine situation er das ist teil einer
situation müssten sagen eine situation
sind deswegen nicht so gute kandidaten
verursachen
ich hatte gemeint ist ein spiel gebracht
ob eine situation möglicher kandidat
verursacht ist erschien das recht
eigentlich gut geeignet das haben wir
mit dem mit dem ursachen begriff alle
bedingungen in sich schließen also mit
der ursache haben wir eigentlich den
begriff dafür dass wir alles hier
zusammen haben was dann bei hinreichend
macht das ist der große vorteil einer
situation aber wir das problem der
situation ist dass wir eben nicht mehr
genau unterscheiden zwischen
randbedingungen und wirklich aktiv
kausalen elementen die notwendig dafür
sind dass das ganze in reichen wird und
deswegen glaube ich das ist der grund
warum man jetzt hier gerade hier jetzt
das einst in dem moment herauspickt und
eben contra faktisch variiert das ist
der grund damit er eben nicht nur von
der situation sprechen muss wie sie sagt
ja
also blieben auf uns wissen was
tatsächlich in der musiker
genau sagen
aber wir bieten wir können die
bestattungen und verhinderten mit
die brauchen
das anfangs ohne dass irgendjemand den
bau und umfassen
dort wird eine hochkomplizierte 100
seiten und küchenhelfer umfassenden
noch dazu möglichst einfache definition
was soll das anders sein
also dass nun dass der ausschuss kann
man in wales bei allen
auch die auch also die andere doch von
anderen dingen sind die wirklich
nachweisen können um die kostüme passen
das ist der rechtlichen
festgelegen was sowie das herzig
verboten ist war schon jetzt
damit sie sich vorstellt
was hält
zuvor zählte man aussagen
aber eines wissen zum präziseren
darstellen
massenheim ist also die relation von
zwei wege beschreiten geworden ist
dieselbe
durch
sondern dass der firma
die einladungen an den kokosnüssen was
man kann sagen sowohl einen positiven
lauf dass der ex- wollen wir natürlich
auch total liebe kommt so dass man kein
anziehen
es umfasse nur noch
ja also ich denke sie haben ja da haben
sie völlig recht und das würde auch
david luiz sofort zu geben dass er dass
er probleme mit hat er versucht jetzt
halt einfach mal eine andere
herangehensweise an das phänomen der
kausalität einfach mal wir wollen das
ganze mal nicht regula ried es
theoretisch betrachtet immer contra
faktisch und dann wollen wir mal schauen
ob das unseren begriff von kausalität
wenn wir klare macht das ist durchaus
pragmatisch ist also der will jetzt hier
nicht dass die perfekte theorie oder so
behaupten sie möchte einfach mal in
anderen zugang wählen
sein braucht es alles
nicht mehr gedacht werden haben viele so
etwas muss man natürlich sagen was macht
man wenn man sich nach wissen will sagen
die eltern sogar das sind für
genau das ist dann nicht eine
feinanalyse aber was hier sackten
juristisch ist ja ein ich praktisch
diene das ist die idee konnte
contra faktisch erlösung also hat dann
hat damit hat der view ist eigentlich
gar nichts neues gemacht völlig richtig
[Musik]
genau aber es ist ja sagen zu recht man
muss es klar man kann das kolleg konter
faktisch kondition kondition also
generell fassen dass wegen der urknall
nicht gewesen wäre dann hätte dieser
mörder diesen mord nicht begangen
mit dem urknall genaueres muss adäquat
sein es muss muss adäquat sein und da
kommt jetzt wieder der begriff der
situationen spielen und deswegen findet
ihn so wichtigen begriff der situation
der situation ist ein begriff der
verständlichkeit einer bestimmten lage
einer möglichen welt der abgegrenzt ist
und der alle bedingungen enthält um so
eine - bedingung machen zu können als es
praktisch der kleinste mögliche bereich
von ereignissen der eine konstante eine
situation konzentriert innerhalb derer
eine ios analyse möglich ist und es gibt
natürlich viele andere bereiche wo man
könnte die situation noch größer fassen
man cannabis zurück bis an den urknall
oder ich weiß nicht wohin aber dann ist
es redundant sein wird das ist die
kleinste mögliche situation die sich
eben - mäßig analysieren lässt
[Musik]
ja also ich denke ich denke eben dass es
durchaus seine lebensweltlich analyse
gibt lebensweltlich analyse von
situationen die eben zum verständnis
dieser wirkung notwendig es ist also und
das ist eben da spielen eben die
ereignissen usa keine rolle für den
hausbrand und der urknall spielt vom vom
sinn her also einfach jetzt nicht nicht
nur von den kausalketten die bis ins
unendliche laufen einfach von dem
begriff brand vor den begriff für das
verständnis eines hausbrandes spielt
einfach der ordner keine rolle
der ist semantisch damit in keiner
verbindung stehen es geht einfach ein
verwaltungssystem da bist
ja richtig aber ich denke die contra
faktisch analyse setzt an dieser enos
bedingung an die setzt also an diesem
setting an was begrenzt ist und pickt
einfach dieses element der das moment
der ursache heraus und modelliert das
contra faktisch also es gibt einfach
glaube es geht um lebensweltlich
zusammenhänge die ebenso eine minimal
bedingungen situativ erfassen die dann
kleinst möglich ist um noch hinreichend
zu sein
die kleinstmögliche menge die zusammen
eine situation ergibt die gerade noch
hinreichend ist das so müsste man das
sagen
natürlich kann man hier noch
verschiedene andere punkte mitnehmen
aber dann wird das nicht mehr
verständlich werden dann wäre das nicht
mehr adäquat für den hausbrand als
einfach im begriffs horizont des
hausbrandes zählen eben manche spiele
nicht wirklich eine rolle
manche ereignisse keine rolle obwohl sie
natürlich streng genommen durchaus
irgendwie sie mal vielleicht verursacht
haben aber einfach vom vom
sinnzusammenhang spielen sie keine rolle
man klammert sie aus aber mit guten
gründen würde
ich habe die ist dies aber dies nicht
kontingents an die ist durchaus
begründet wir sagen jetzt schon
begründet durch das setting einfach
durch dass die vorgegebene us durch die
wirkung
ja ich würde nicht sagen mehr tun aber
ich würde auch sagen nicht nur die
anwendung von regeln sind ebenso
holistischen holistische sicht es geht
um zusammenhänge es geht uns zusammen
dinge die eben die eben länger sind und
zusammenhänge die sehr lose sind und es
geht eben um eine kohärenz würde jetzt
mal sagen eine kohärenz von situation
einer situation die ebenso eine kuh renz
die so stark so mächtig ist dass sie
eben uns das ganze verstehen ist gerade
und ich glaube dass wir sogar
verständlich problem hätten für die
wirkung wenn wir noch den urknall mit
rein nehmen würden ich glaube dass uns
das ganze dadurch nicht verständlicher
wird es im gegenteil es würde uns die
unverständliche werden also wir
verstehen die ursache wirklich nur dann
gut wenn er möglichst klein ist
überschaubar ist in diesen elementen
dass der situation wenn die situation
wirklich überschaubar ist wie wir die
situation zu weit machen verstehen wir
die ursache gar nicht mehr oder die das
was in der usa in der situation
ursächlich ist
vier jahre
vielleicht denken die euro gestanden
wäre
von unserer weltweiten könnte ich für
ausgeschlossen
[Musik]
ja also ich denke es ist eine ganz
komplexe sache ich denke wir haben den
punkt verstanden ja aber es ist gut dass
ich darauf hinweisen weil es einfach
darum geht wie wir jetzt hier die das
alte cds fassen und ich möchte jetzt
einfach mal weitergehen er will nämlich
nur singuläre fälle von kausalität
betrachten
es handelt sich also nicht um eine
analyse kausaler verallgemeinerungen
das sind vermutlich also kausale folge
meinungen sind versagt er vermutlich
quantifizierte aussagen in denen
wiederum die kausalität zwischen
einzelereignissen oder nicht ereignis
eine rolle spielt er weiß ist er weiß
nicht aber nicht als einfach den
kausalen verallgemeinerung der
natürlichen sprache verfügbare
quantifizierte formen zuzuordnen so kann
zb satz der form c ereignisse also c ist
jetzt groß geschrieben
das also ereignisse des typs c c
ereignisse verursachen ereignisse des
typs a bis c bedeutet also folgenden und
jetzt gibt es hier eben verschiedene
leser und das habe ich jetzt mal hier
direkt raus kopiert also es brauchen
jetzt nicht im detail betrachten aber
dass die sehne sind eben diese analyse
also arm ist eine möglichkeit es gibt
ein c also ein token sozusagen ein
trocken aus dem typ also ein
einzelereignis des unter c fällt aus c
und eine auslese das gilt c verursachte
und so weiter so faul als gibt es ganz
verschiedene ganz verschiedene lesarten
ja
hier handelt zeigt der ganzen fluss hier
handelt es sich aber um probleme die
unsere qualifizierten ausdrücke
betreffen und nicht um kausal probleme
also es geht jetzt hier sagen um leser
das hatten sie sich gemeldet
[Musik]
ja das wäre jetzt was genau das wäre
jetzt eine eine frage ein test ein
testverfahren für was für die
ursächlichkeit des kurzschluss oder
verfassen
[Musik]
das werden alle handlungen die
möglichkeit die gute frage wie sehen es
die anderen teilnehmer überzeugt sich
diese diese analyse
sie wollen neben damit suchen diese
anderen bedingungen auszuschalten
letztendlich in dieser hand bedingung
das bezog sich darauf oder das bezog es
nicht das war jetzt einfach nur generell
gefragt ja da haben sie aber auch schon
so eine praktischen derart kondition
lernen die analyse schon ein bisschen
unternommen da die ihrem beispiel jetzt
oder ja also ich denke ich denke das
geht in die richtige richtung also in
diesem cd kondition ahlen haaranalyse
dass man fragt man betrachtet das ganze
von hinten
was hätte sein müssen damit das nicht
passiert oder passiert wenn ich denke
das geht in diese richtung der kausalen
der contra faktischen analyse und da
müssen wir jetzt weitermachen
und zwar dann springe ich jetzt mal
diese ganzen randbedingungen und jetzt
geht es um diese komparative ähnlichkeit
ist jetzt ganz wichtig da hatten hatte
der kommilitone vorhin darauf
hingewiesen sie auf diese möglichen
welten das ist jetzt also diese diese
ähnlichkeit der möglichen welten also
wir betrachten nur ganz ganz geringe
abweichungen im verlauf der möglichen
welten also zunächst nämlich als
grundbegriff die relation der
komparativen gesamt ähnlichkeit zwischen
möglich welten wir können dann sagen
dass die eine welt näher an der
wirklichkeit ist also an unserer
wirklichen welt als die andere wenn die
erste nachdem alle ähnlichkeiten und
unterschieden betracht gezogen worden
und gegeneinander abgewogen worden sind
der wirklichen welt ähnlicher ist als
die zweite allgemeine gesagt ist es so
dass eine beliebige welt wie die rolle
unsere wirklichen welt spielen kann wenn
ich von unserer wirklichen welt rede
ohne genau zu wissen welche welt die uns
richtet ist so generale sichere ich ein
über alle wild in wahrheit brauchen wir
als eine dreistellige relation
bild wie ist näher an welt wie einst
müssen uns sein als welt wie zwei also
eine kompass zur kooperation ist immer
eine dreistellige relation da muss
glaube ich im originaltext wie einst
stehen glaube ich oder das einst habe
ich rausgenommen hier wenn sie mal
schauen
bild wie ist näher an die welt jetzt
müssen wir drei ist ja nicht das müssen
ja drei seien also das muss
wahrscheinlich
es hat also wie auch sie verstehen
punkten es werden zwei welten leben mit
einer verglichen
also schon jetzt hier stehen erst
richtig ich habe nur den index 1 der
index 1 fehlt bei mir durch zu
übernehmen genau es genauso dreistellige
relation genommen also wird einfach
verglichen
etwas wirklich was ist am nächsten
da ich nicht gesagt habe wie die aspekte
unter den wirklichen wird genau wie
genannte abgewogen werden habe ich auch
nicht gesagt was unsere relation der
komparativen ähnlichkeit genau sein soll
ich nannte sie nicht umsonst einen
grundbegriff ich habe aber gesagt welche
art die relation ist und mit dieser sind
wir vertraut wir bilden uns aufgrund
komparative gesamt ähnlichkeit urteil
zum beispiel menschen indem wir eine
ganze menge verschiedener arten von
ähnlichkeiten und unterschiede
gegeneinander abwägen
unsere gegenseitigen erwartungen von
denen von den zu gewinnenden faktoren
sind dabei oft bestimmt und genau genug
um kommunikation zu erlauben
und er setzt erst ein pragmatisches
argument also um halt zu recht zu kommen
ich werde später noch mehr darüber sagen
wie das abwägen in speziellen fällen vor
sich gehen muss damit meine analyse auch
funktioniert das vage an der gesamt
ähnlichkeit wird aber nicht ganz
verschwinden das sollte es auch nicht
denn keine korrekte analyse kann
bestreiten dass sich die vagheit der
ähnlichkeit auf die kausalität überträgt
das ist genau der punkt als er gibt es
zu da ist ein gewisser form von rest war
kein abends einfach pragmatisch gesehen
wir kommen damit so zurecht in der
lebenswelt
[Musik]
identität kann man schon definiert
intimität schon ähnlichkeit ist ein
problem aber identität kam also gut
natürlich klar man logisch kann man
identität eben sehr gut modellieren das
problem halt der ähnlichkeit ist
schwierig also was ähnlich immer in
gewisser hinsicht ähnlich wie viele
momente müssen jetzt ähnlich sein damit
wir überhaupt das noch sagen können das
natürlich eine graduelle geschichte
identität gibt es eben die numerische
identität oder irgendeine andere form
von identität damit verschiedene sinne
von identität aber dass identität ist
eben ein strikter begriff als eben
ähnlichkeiten und deswegen ist eben
identität leichter logisch zu
modellieren als es ihm ähnlichkeit ist
aber es natürlich auch mal muss man
wieder den punkt betrachtet das
identifizieren systemischen aspekt dass
wir irgendwas als derselbe anerkennen
und da kommen dann wieder wach halten
ins spiel ganz klar
das nicht
ja ich glaube nicht weil ich glaube
nicht dass lou ist eine piste also dass
er seine theorie der möglichen welt
epidemisch also aufgrund eines
erkenntnistheoretischen problems
formuliert sondern es ist ein logisches
argument also nicht nur aufgrund von
systemischer einschränkungen oder
aufgrund von wahrheit dass er von
möglicher welt spricht er möchte einfach
eine intuition unserer unseres kausal
verständnisses besonders betonen und das
ist einfach hier diese notwendigkeit die
aber eben gerade über die möglichkeit
definiert er sagt die möglichkeit ist
das entscheidende
die wirkliche welt und das ist natürlich
wir gehen bei generellen beschreibung
der regular ried bei regular readers
beschreibung der kausalität gehen wie
immer von der wirklichen welt aus die
wirkliche welt und er möchte jetzt mal
das ganze von der mögliche von einer
möglichen welt betrachten
da müsste es einen boom geben wieso die
reißt mich nicht wirklich
in der hand hat
ja das ist ja also ich heute morgen
verstanden hätte dann wäre ich nicht
gekommen also dann wäre ich jetzt anders
sie sind die sich jetzt das kann ich mir
vorstellen dass ich hätte genau
angeguckt
ich werde jetzt aber sieben vielleicht
ich glaube dass diskutiert weil sie sich
nicht viel anders
wir sind natürlich in der 2
ja ja es ist ja nicht der grund für
diese halt nicht nur sagen ich habe
kunden ist es nicht was also noch sieht
man eben aufgestanden und warum sind sie
nicht nicht aufgestanden
das ist ja keine werbung mehr bekommen
[Musik]
ja also das ist ein wichtiger punkt weil
letztendlich wenn man dann von akteurs
kausalität redet und so dann hängt das
natürlich mit unserer menschlichen
freiheit zusammen
und dann kommt die große frage
determinismus und freiheit ins spiel und
das ist dann eine ganz spannende sache
also wie man eben auch also auch
freiheit wird häufig contra faktisch
beschriebene also wenn ich das nicht
getan hätte dann wäre das nicht passiert
also wir reden jetzt nur über ereignis
kausale contra faktisch analysen
man kann natürlich auch akteurs kausale
ereignisse contra faktisch analysieren
und dann also ich meine es so im sinne
der möglichen welten kann man eben dann
immer bei uns sagen das ist eben
visierten es eben nicht widersprüchlich
das widerspricht nicht dem logischen
gesetzen da sich das auch anders hätte
machen können und so aber dann stellt
man sich eben die frage wie fügt sich
jetzt diese entscheidung diese andere
entscheidung
die schließt die sich an den kausalen
nexus der vor mir war an wie schließt
sie sich an gibt es dann plötzlich hier
also wie kann ich diese diese das ist
praktisch die vorgängige kausal welt und
wie kann ich dann so eine abzweigung
hier möglich machen wie kann ich die aus
den vorherigen die erklären das ist ein
riesenproblem und da gibt es
verschiedene
aus irgendwelchen gründen ist dieses
paar nicht gefahren dann wäre auch nicht
irgendein ereignis gewesen
das hat es so nicht gewesen
es ist ja denkbar dass der weiche
der strecke schwer und ich werde nicht
mehr kommen
das ist logisch auf jeden fall möglich
logisch ist es möglich die frage ist
halt sie gerade noch
verträgt und es gibt einiges was für uns
denkbar ist und es ist auch denkbar dass
die s-bahn
und meint es denkbar dass diese trotz
dem 1 tatsächlich der fall das heißt
wenn diesmal wirklich zu spät gekommen
wäre es auch lieber wenn es noch der
er hätte von
also wenn ihr 20 jahr das 5
das wahlergebnis sei möglich indem die
möglichkeiten des films also so hörmann
mit ausnahme ist so ein bisschen dieser
dieser freiheitsgeschichte weil also
genau nur im sinne jetzt diese ereignis
kausalität wenn man jetzt eben von
akteuren nicht von stammstrecken und so
ereignet wenn ich jetzt da eben der
wecker klingelt und jetzt gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten ich kann liegenbleiben
willentlich oder ich kann aufstehen und
es ich habe beides gründe
und wenn ich jetzt eben wenn ich daneben
versuche diese an diese bifurkation
diese zwei möglichkeiten hier zu sehen
dann stellt sich eben die frage wie
schließt sich die eine oder andere an
dem vorherigen consult nexus ankommt da
plötzlich so eine ganz neue ursache
einfach so rein und dann haben ein
problem ist es natürlich an schließt an
die vergangenheit ja bitte
genau ebendieser
ja
wir müssen jetzt auch jetzt kommt er
gleich zum punkt wir sind ja bisher nur
noch so im vorlauf hier und jetzt kommt
er eben gleich zu diesem punkt das dass
er eben jetzt hier
diese analyse jetzt mal unternimmt
[Musik]
wenn ich kenne das noch aus der
britischen wissenschaftler und andere
vorsieht
er war sicherlich nicht der erste der so
solche gedanken belegung hatte aber der
dass auf den qualitätsbegriff bezogener
glaube ich schon also wirkmächtig also
besonders laboriert hat im ganzen mal so
eine logische form gegeben
dafür ist er glaube ich sehr berühmt
also es gibt bestimmt vorläufer gedanken
der contra faktischen analyse aber das
kann in so eine logische form zu gießen
wie es jetzt gleich tot ich glaube da
ist dieser aufsatz sehr berühmt dafür
dass glauben 173 oder so erschienen 74
das passt eben zu seinem ganzen denken
zusammen zu diesem möglichen melden
das buchbar gemacht
[Musik]
so hätten sie gemacht auch schon anfang
des letzten jahres
weil man so dass es da also kommen
aber eben jetzt bezogen auf so eine
kausale analyse und unlogische
modellierung und mögliche welt mit dass
dann noch mit leuten zusammenzubringen
das ist einfach so aus einem guss zu
machen denkt dafür ist halt recht
berühmt das wird eben mit seinem namen
häufig kommentiert da gibt es sicherlich
wie bei allem immer ganz viele einflüsse
und auch viele quellen die er jetzt
nicht explizit machen das ist natürlich
immer schwierig jetzt im einzel zu sagen
das hat diejenige schon vor mir gemacht
und der und hier 1000 jahre vorher und
so aber ganz klar leibnitz wie sie
sagten ist eben ganz wichtig für lewis
das ist eben über dem hintergrund dass
mögliche welt und jetzt schau mal unsere
relation der compart die dreistellige
relation der komparativen ähnlichkeit
sollte zwei formalen bedingungen genügen
ersten sie sollte eine schwache ordnung
über die welt sein eine ordnung die
gleich ordnung erlaubt in der aber zwei
beliebige bilden immer vergleichbar sind
keine andere welt ist unserer wirklichen
welt ähnlicher als sie sich selbst sie
kommt deshalb der wirklichkeit am
nächsten wir verlangen darüber hinaus
aber nicht das ist in einer beliebigen
menge aber von wilden genau einen extra
welt gibt oder auch nur eine menge von
gleich geordneten nächsten a welt warum
sollte es denn keine folge gegeben die
zwar keinen extra welt hat aber aus
unendlich immer näher welten steht
in mehreren ländern
dann versuchte er versuche jetzt einfach
identität über ähnlichkeiten zu
reformieren
also also man kann dann eben das als
eine mediation als identität
das ist eben identität ist eben immer so
eine geschichte weil es eben das problem
des theologischen dann gibt er versucht
hier eben dass die tautologie zu
vermeiden nehmen sagt ich fasse
identität über ähnlichkeit die einfach
ganz genau
ganz genau dass die die größtmögliche
ähnlichkeit und dann kann eben wenn man
eben mit möglichen welten operiert muss
man eben mit ähnlichkeit mit
komparativen ähnlichkeiten zu operieren
er möchte einfach identität re
formulieren über eine dreistellige
relation und weil das problem ist der
identität ist sie eine zweistellige
relation und er möchte jetzt
offensichtlich identität als eine
dreistellige relation fassen und
deswegen muss eben bei identität als ein
sonderfall von der nächsten sprechen ja
dieser zeitung
so eine kompatible jede konfrontation
land gebrannt hätte die männlichkeit
kann sich die verpassen möchte das nicht
so dass es scheint mir total auf
gezwungen sein diese welt in einer welt
in der ein meter links stehen sowohl
eine karte rechts steht
ich glaube nicht dass man objektiv klar
sagen kann welche dieser okay gut und
auch nicht dass man gewisse sagen
zugleich genau dass diese tiefe ist
reinhold ähnlichkeit
es scheint nichts funktionieren und das
geht eben zahlen aber es geht nicht so
sehr bei welten einzige
das kranken menschen erleben
die genau also guter punkt zum beispiel
jetzt wenn wir uns mal zwei mögliche
weltall sowie 1 also oder wie 0 und wie
12 wir haben drei bild wir haben als
unsere wirkliche welt sowieso hier ist
und jetzt haben eine mögliche welt in
der dieser stuhl hier auf dem tisch
steht das ist eine und eine andere
mögliche welt wo der stuhl unter dem
tisch liegt so welche welt ist dieser
zwei welt ist jetzt unsere nähe
ähnlicher also die entscheid barkeit ist
auch ein bisschen probleme ist die jetzt
nährt wo der stuhl drüber auf den tisch
geht oder models darunter ist sowas ist
jetzt also ins normale zweistellig
gegeben also die größe sollte
messbar aber kostet weil ich die
situation
t shirts
das ist ein wert also die ähnlichkeit
sprechen und identität und ich glaube
dass entscheiden ist ähnlich eben in
bezug auf kausalität das ist glaube ich
hier das entscheidende also es geht
jetzt hier eben um diese dieses amt cds
was eben hinreichend werden muss und die
ähnlichkeit wird wenn ich es recht sie
daran bemessen ob eben dieselbe wirkung
herauskommt unter diesen umständen und
daran wird eben die ähnlichkeit gemessen
an der kausalen relevanz
so kann er nicht ich denke er möchte
einfach das ganze verständlicher machen
also er möchte ebenfalls
unterscheidungen treffen
also wenn ich jetzt eben hier einfach
verschiedene spielarten habe was
passiert dann kommt dann das raus ich
variiere das so lange und schaue eben
ich variiere die mögliche welt und
schaue wie viel kann ich variieren damit
immer noch das rauskommt wir machen
einfach machen einfachen test nur wir
fühlen da beliebiges rein mögliche
welten und schauen einfach was kommt
raus was passiert dann
[Musik]
das ist ein guter punkt ja also das muss
man noch genauer betrachten aber direkte
grund einsicht ist einfach die wir
variieren und schauen was kommt raus und
wenn man das eben die variation
betrachten unter dem aspekt der gleiche
wirkung
dann haben wir schon so ein bisschen so
einen fokus worauf wir besonders wert
legen können worauf also 18 es ist kaum
saal relevant natürlich kann es jetzt
wird die zirkuläre seien aber geht
einfach um den exekutiven gewinn dieser
geschichte
allerdings muss
und ja also ich glaube dass ebenso vor
wie so ein testverfahren und so ein
testverfahren erfüllt da irgendwas ein
und schauen was kommt raus und und wo
passiert es noch und wo eben nicht mehr
und da wo es eben nicht mehr wo nicht
nur die wirkung rauskommt damals halten
interessanten feiern und sie will neben
dann gar nicht gewesen wäre wäre nichts
gewesen
also einfach wir vergleichen eben sehr
ähnliche welten und schauen wenn wir
jetzt etwas verändern was kommt raus so
und das ist glaube ich so der der
betrachtungswinkel den er sich hier
sofort genommen hat und jetzt müssen wir
halt schauen ob durch so eine
perspektive auf die welt ob dadurch
kausalität als phänomen eben
verständlicher wird als es eben in einer
rede preise von regula rät das ist jetzt
so ein bisschen diese frage und jetzt
sagte er folgendes als kontra faktische
kondition aale und contra faktische
abhängigkeit und jetzt habe ich das
ganze hier raus kopiert weil ich einfach
mit der kopierfunktion diese kästchen da
nicht zur entwicklung ich will nicht
wissen was dann daraus gekommen wäre
muss das so machen also wellen zwei
beliebige pro positionen a und c gegeben
sind und haben wir auch das ihnen
entsprechende contra faktische kondition
ahlen und dieses komische kästen teil
dann zieht das heißt die proposition
wenn aw war wäre dann wäre auch cbs
müsste sich glaube ich auf seite 109 110
befinden der textsammlung des textes
die operation mittels dieses kästchen
den pfeil wird mittels einer wahrheits
regel folgendermaßen definiert kästchen
plc iss war in einer welt wie genau dann
wenn entweder gilt erstens es gibt keine
möglichen welten diesem fall ist
kästchen 2c trivial war
oder zweitens es gibt eine welt in der
auch c gilt und sie kommt näher an sie
heran als bewegend eine andere welt in
der c nicht gilt
anders ausgedrückt ein kontra faktisches
konditionell ist nicht trivial war genau
dann wenn gilt man muss weniger von der
wirklichkeit abweichen um den fördersatz
zusammen mit dem hinter satz wahr zu
machen als man abweichen muss um den
fördersatz ohne den hinter satz war zwar
was haben sie dazu sagen werden
mehr und mehr sind bekannt
und über libyen
ähnlichkeiten zu beziehen sind das
individuell festlegen welche welt jetzt
also was ich anders und in der welt
dessen nicht habe meine lehrerin
abzustellen und das nicht nicht dass es
im fall stehe nicht an sondern es ja
also ich weiß so recht auf dieses
problem der ähnlichkeit hin
andere meinungen noch dazu
also ich glaube nicht dass sie das um
den besten hinterlässt aber einen
eindruck wie man es vielleicht nicht mal
das
weiter in die vergangenheit
unser kontakt dann bei einer scherbe
ja
kraft mit anderen ergebnissen zurück
unterstellt man da vielleicht gegenübers
bahnverkehr auf die hinterbeine zeiten
in denen simon aller kraft der
ähnlichkeit gerufen
ja also ich denke mit etwas aussuchen
man muss das auf eine strategie
festlegen
sie schleuderten die täter fassen weil
diese am besten funktionieren kann was
über eine minimale änderung vor zehn
jahren eine viel geringere wenn du bist
was eine sehr große trennung des kann
dass man im besten auto befreit werden
müssen
natürlich läuft seit mehreren und seine
neue freundin von zehn jahren
1000 absolventen im 1
danke
also das ist ein guter punkt also dass
wir jetzt hier einfach gewisse begriffe
voraussetzt diese sachverhalte
voraussetzt ohne dann im konkreten
zeigen zu können ob es denn funktioniert
so einfach mal weiter wir haben nicht
vorausgesetzt dass es immer eine oder
mehrere nächstgelegene abend gibt wenn
es aber welche gibt vereinfacht sich die
sache folgendermaßen als eine art wesen
wir dann wird sie ist nicht trivial war
genau dann wenn zehn allen
nächstgelegenen anwältin gilt wir haben
nicht vorausgesetzt dass a falsch ist
wenn aber ist dann ist unsere wirkliche
welt die nächstgelegene welt wir die
identität mit next gelegen und somit ist
kästchen pfeil 10 war genau dann wenn
sie ist deshalb folgt aus kästchen fall
zedi material indikation impliziert c&a
und c zusammen folgt a kästchen vcm
jetzt natürlich sehr sehr schematisch
und also wie gesagt da sind einmal
schauen dieses kästchen fall c liest man
folgendermaßen wenn aber wahr wäre dann
wäre auch zäh war das ist jetzt die
geräte meist
wie verstehen haben sie jetzt da noch
eine information rausziehen können die
für unser qualitätsverständnis relevant
ist das sehr sehr formal und haus erst
ein bisschen durchaus konter intuitiv
vom formuliert haben sie dann auch ein
paar der orientierungen die uns
weiterhelfen können mit bezug auf die
kausalität frage
schnelligkeit auf werden muss und die
einstigen wenn ich keine einigung
missbrauch möglich sind neben der
möglichkeit aber in fast allen möglichen
dieses gleichzeitig vermögen wirklich
notwendig ist aber ein anderer punkt um
die möglichkeit den test versionen zu
schaffen
zeichnen einen glücklichen möglich
nächstenliebe sie gilt wer nicht weiß
und dass die ersetzung möglich durch
beiden nächsten begeben werden das muss
man einkaufen und ein persönliches ist
natürlich nicht ist die also nochmal
wiederholt also not die frage ist eben
wie man die notwendigkeit notwendig
verbindung analysiert was notwendig ist
dann muss es eben in allen möglichen
welten zu sein ja das hatten sie sich
gefolgt
[Musik]
die nachweisen können
das ist eben jetzt ein ästhetisches
problem
[Musik]
und mit solchen komplizierten
erklärungen ist auch mal gesagt
ja ja jetzt hat man eben ästhetisches
problem was man noch unterscheiden
müsste vom logischen probleme sie haben
sich gemeldet
wenn wir einfach seinen standort unseren
genannten fällen zu fragen
ansprechende übersichtliche weise von
opel nicht
die bahn stellt sich ja egal natürlich
werden sie uns
von unserem
und hier deswegen böse wenn ich genug
das ist in allen durch weite ferne und
wenn man das kauft dann kann man
versuchen dieses geschäft wird euch das
sind extraversion
das ist ein schwieriges unterfangen das
ist dann auch kompliziert machen
darstellung widerspricht aber nicht
komplett weil sind die industrie
fragen gestellt aber
nun stellt ist nicht notwendig das
publikum will begriff kausalität zu
sehen
das aber guter punkt ja aber moment mal
das ist ein guter punkt weil sie haben
jetzt zu recht darauf hingewiesen wie
kommen praktisch jetzt wir werden weiter
es wird weitergereicht
das haben sie gerade beschrieben wir
werden jetzt sagen weiter geleitet vom
problem der kausalität plötzlich sind
wir jetzt ein problem der notwendigkeit
und vom problem der notwendigkeit kommen
jetzt auf das problem der möglichen
welten
das haben sie also völlig richtig
beschrieben jetzt kann das jetzt aber
auch anders sehen dann kann das
verstehen als ein fortschritt im sinne
der expedition wir werden jetzt einfach
von einem begriff zum nächsten verwiesen
und analysieren ihn mit anderen
begriffen und da würde jetzt eben louis
sagen das ist ein gewinn ein extra
tiefer gewinnen das wird es eben bei dem
wir waren wir waren hier bei der regular
ried gewesen und kommen jetzt davon zur
notwendigen bedingungen und zum von der
notwendigen bedingungen kommen wir zur
theorie der möglichen welten das heißt
analysieren das ganze einfach immer
anderes mit anderen begriffen und die
frage ist halt das ist philosophie
analytische analytische philosophie
[Musik]
sie haben
sie haben sicherlich recht dass das eine
weitere analyse ist die frage ist halt
ob man nicht wenn man weiter analysiert
das ganze dann plötzlich am ende
verständlicher bekommt es halt die frage
jetzt hatten sie sich gemeldet
migration
so überrascht es gibt
hierbei
weil ich hatte wie gesagt und gemeint
sind dies nicht die mafia nicht geeignet
zu beschreiben jetzt gebaut werden
nun bestimmte aspekte eben der
kausalität eskalation zu beleuchten aber
sie wollten gleich dazu und außer und st
da kommt eben noch diese ganzen
möglichen welt mit rein brauchen eben
die material implikation modelliert im
also mit möglichen welten und noch um in
einer gewissen umgebung und dann können
wir die eben schon benutzen aber alleine
können wir sie eben nicht verwenden weil
dann haben wir viele probleme wenn man
die contra position machen
also würde daraus folgen wenn nicht dann
nicht
und dann haben wir eben wenn man dann
die zeit logik und so weiter kommt auch
noch alles mit rein also dass es
geklappt so nicht aber man kann es eben
mit dieser contra faktischen geschichte
durchaus besser modellieren ja aber noch
mal zurück auf ihren punkt ich glaube
sie haben den punkt jetzt endlich
getroffen sie bewerten ihm jetzt anders
als in juiz bewerten würde
aber es ist eine analyse wir kommen von
einem begriff auf den nächsten und wir
landen am ende da wo wir nie glaubten
hinke kommen zu können
wir wundern uns wie kommen wir jetzt
bitte von kausalität zu einem möglichen
welt ist hat doch miteinander gar nichts
zu tun
aber das ist doch gerade das
interessante also eine analyse ist doch
dann umso interessanter ist je weniger
wird damit rechnen dass wir dort mal
anders als praktisch mit dann trifft der
möglichen welt qualität besser verstehen
können ist doch mal erst mal erstaunlich
und alles was erstaunlich ist es einfach
informativ und bringt uns in der analyse
weiter
das würde er jetzt wohl darauf antworten
hat das einfach damit ganz scheinbar
entgegengesetzte bereiche der
philosophie damit in eine verbindung
gebracht werden können
extra tief wenn auch analytisch und klar
wie analysieren uns da eben weiter wir
wollen jetzt auch nicht mehr
das ist vielleicht noch ein gutes gutes
beispiel war jetzt bringt da etwas
konkretes sagte contra faktisch
abhängigkeit zwischen großen familien
von alternativen ist typisch ms
wahrnehmungs und kontrolle vorgänger
angenommen r1 r2 und so weiter seine
positionen die verschieden die die
verschiedenen barometer anzeigen eines
bestimmten barometers zu verschiedenen
zeitpunkten zum inhalt haben und mit p1
p2 und so weiter seien die
entsprechenden luftdruck werte wieder
geben
wenn das barometer richtig funktioniert
müssen die erst contra faktisch von den
ps abhängen
das heißt der barometer stand hängt vom
luftdruck
ähnliches gilt für meine visuellen
wahrnehmung wenn ich zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt um mich schauen müssen sie bei
einer großen menge alternativen
möglichkeiten contra faktisch von der
szenerie meine augen abhängen und es
muss sogar eine doppelte contra
faktische abhängigkeit vorliegen wenn
ich einen geschehen in gewisser hinsicht
bestimmen kann wiederum haben wir einen
ziemlich großen bereich von alternativen
das ergebnis hängt davon ab was ich tue
und das wiederum von dem was ich als
ergebnis haben möchte das kann man sich
natürlich fragen wie wie sieht's mit
losen korrelationen aus sind
korrelationen contra faktisch zu
analysieren ich glaube nicht unbedingt
dass er das problem der epi phänomene
hier geht es jetzt jedenfalls bei den
barometern dem luftdruck damals mit
einer kausalen verbindung zu tun weil
der luftdruck der verursacht eben die
barometer anzeigt und zwar physikalisch
ich weiß genau so wie jetzt nicht
angekommen jaja entgegengenommen haben
ich meinte nicht die kooperation an sich
sondern die geleistet oder als würde er
immer noch in auf einigen portalen
zusammen genau ich nicht behaupten
wollen
sie müssen sich notwendigerweise aber
sie können es ja
besten kooperationen unserer seite
hätten dann würde man hier über die
auch die korrelation bekommen ja alle
das ist jedenfalls noch mal eine
interessante beschreibung einfach der
kommissar abhängigkeit das nächste mal
kurz durch kausale abhängigkeit zwischen
ereignissen ist eine familie c1 c2 eben
erklärten sinne von einer familie a1 a2
contra faktisch abhängig werden wir
gewöhnlich auch von kausaler
abhängigkeit reden wollen so sagen wird
zum beispiel dass die jeweilige gibt
dass der jeweilige barometer stand vom
luftdruck kausal abhängig ist dass meine
visuellen wahrnehmung kausal abhängig
sind von der szenerie von meinen augen
und dass die das ergebnis eines
geschehens auf dass ich bestimmt einige
kann kausal abhängig ist von dem was ich
tue und das reicht jetzt einfach nur mal
bis dahin als wir können jetzt eben
contra faktische abhängigkeit die als
solche noch nicht kausal ist das ist der
punkt also konto faktische abhängigkeit
sagt noch nichts über kausalität aus
erstmal aber die können wir eben dann
sehr gut zur erklärung von kausalitäten
benutzt ja ich glaube dass noch mal
wichtig unterschied contra faktische
abhängigkeit heißt nicht dass er um
kausal relation gibt geht also noch
nicht per se aber können es eben sehr
gut dafür verwenden um dieses diesen
gedanken der der notwendigkeit einfach
zu fassen
ja eben über die möglichen welten es
geht einfach um dieselbe sache und
derselbe kausalen phänomen was wir jetzt
mal aus einem ganz anderen blickwinkel
betrachten abhängigkeit was wäre wenn
und über ähnlichkeiten den anderen
möglichen welt
das ist so der punkt es ist einfach eine
andere sicht mehr andere perspektiven
modale sicht auf die kausalität relation
und jetzt weil sie schön ist wenn wir
noch sieben minuten haben kommen wir
noch ganz zum schluss auf diesen netten
herrn hier zurück auf die von kim der
ein aufsatz geschrieben hat mit dem
titel neuen corsa connections und zwar
aus den jahren 1974 in dem er sich
direkt auf david luiz und viele der
anderen von uns bereits behandelten
philosophen bezieht und wir wollen das
jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz rein lesen
also und das ist jetzt hier so ein bezug
auf mac i am anfang also wenn das
streichelt das nicht an der eine
reibefläche gegeben worden wäre hätte es
sich nicht entzündet dieses contra
faktische kondition ahl bringt eine
abhängigkeit beziehung zwischen zwei
ereignissen zum ausdruck dass das
streichholz sich entzündete hängt davon
ab dass das streichholz an einer
reibefläche geschrieben wurde
es handelt sich hier als war praktisch
notwendig
es war notwendig dieses bei es handelt
sich hier um eine kausale abhängigkeit
das treiben des streichholzes
verursachte dass brennendes streichholz
man kann auch sagen die tatsache der
sich entzündete war kausal determiniert
durch das reiben die kausal relation ist
ein beispiel dafür was nicht eine
abhängigkeit beziehung oder
determination beziehung zwischen
ereignissen oder zuständen nenne
bis jetzt ist die kausal relation jedoch
die einzige relation die klar erkannt
und ausführlich diskutiert worden ist
und jetzt wieder nämlich mal eine andere
relation einbringt titel nicht kausalen
relation die dominierende stellung die
der kausale beziehung zu geworden ist
wird beispielsweise dadurch deutlich
dass die these des durchgängigen
determinismus meistens in form von
behauptungen wie jedes ereignis hat eine
ursache aufgestellt wird einer solchen
formulierung wird implizit angenommen
dass determination dasselbe bedeutet wie
verursachen
dies sollte jedoch noch einmal genau
überprüft werden es scheint nämlich
abhängigkeit beziehungen nämlich auch
contra faktisch abhängigkeit beziehung
zwischen ereignissen zu geben die nicht
kausal natur sind
auch kann die these eines durchgängigen
determinismus durchaus richtig sein wie
ich zeigen würde
selbst wenn nicht jedes ereignis eine
ursache hat solche nicht kausalen
abhängigkeits beziehung gibt es überall
im netz von ereignissen und es ist
wichtig ihr wesen ihre gegenseitigen
beziehungen und ihre beziehungen zur
kausal beziehung zu verstehen wenn wir
eine klaren vollständige vorstellung
davon haben möchten wie ereignis sind
dieser welt zusammen hängen dass er
jetzt so unser punkt von vorhin gewesen
ich meinte ja das contra faktische
konditionelle als solche noch nicht
unbedingt kausal zu verstehen sind also
es ist jetzt folgendes möglich wir haben
hier eben eine menge an müll kann contra
faktischen kondition ahlen wir
also das ist jetzt contra faktische
konditionelle kaka und davon jetzt eben
ein bereich und das ist eben kkk das
darf ich nicht schreiben ja ich schreibe
es trotzdem
das ist eben sind eben kausale kontrakt
konditionen
stimmen sie mir zu das ist von den
konter faktischen konditionell das eben
die größere menge ist und dass ihm eine
teilmenge davon gibt die eben kausale
das also eine besondere art davon ist
also prima vater jedenfalls muss es
nicht so sein dass alle contra
faktischen koalition aale kausal sind
das ist ja muss ja noch nicht so sein
dass oder einfach nur
dies sagt der cd ist ereignisse als
renata und es gibt auch automatisch
das wäre eine möglichkeit genau da ich
will jetzt einfach mal offen lassen
einfach nur mal diskutieren
also ja
haben sie beispiel haben sie ein
beispiel
ja und das
das ist richtig und das ist jetzt nicht
kausal das wäre nicht kausal zu
verstehen
das ist richtig genommen das bringt
jetzt ja diese deckung kommt dieses
beispiel ging also gott ist tot und ist
oder dass widmen thum von dexter titel
ist jetzt ja nicht direkt kausal
verbunden also es ist aber voneinander
abhängig auch begrifflich dass der punkt
es ist begrifflich voneinander abhängig
also sogar das natürlich wenn sokrates
stirbt tritt der fall ein dass sein
titel so genannt werden kann aber es ist
rein begrifflich determiniert also eben
die die wissenschaft wird eben definiert
durch den tod des mannes und genauso
umgedrehten dh es ist eine begriffliche
abhängigkeit und die begriffliche
abhängigkeit die bringt uns viel näher
in der nähe eines analytischen satzes
alles eben also eines analytischen
satzes und nicht eines synthetischen
satz 2 bei kausalität relation haben das
um synthetische haben wir es mit
synthetischen verhältnissen zu tun also
deswegen kann man hier eben sagen es
gibt eben noch andere mengen die eben
nicht kausal abhängigkeiten sind und
darauf hat eben check von kim noch
hingewiesen und man wenn man eben jetzt
david luiz liest dann scheint es so zu
sein dass eben alle contra faktischen
kondition aale kausal sind dann meint
man dass es schnell vertrieben das ist
derselbe sind der analyse
aber es eben nicht so es gibt eben
offensichtlich noch andere fälle wo es
abhängigkeiten gibt die aber nicht
kausal verursacht gedacht werden müssen
sind einfach in begrifflicher
abhängigkeiten und dann wäre eben eine
spannende frage wie man das eben nimmt
und eben wie man eben diese diese nicht
diese nicht kausale abhängigkeit nimmt
und man könnte sie durchaus auch
determination beziehung nehmen wie es
hier tut aber eben determination
beziehung nicht in kausalem sinne
das problem ist ja wenn wir an
determination denken denken wir gleich
dass da was kausal beeinflusst wird
aber das muss nicht so sein es wird
einfach nur bestimmt in seiner bedeutung
und bestimmung muss nicht kausal sein
als das heißt wir neigen dazu vielleicht
ein gutes schlusswort jetzt wir neigen
dazu alle beziehungen alle engen
beziehungen immer schon kausal zu
verstehen also wenn wir sehr engen
abhängigkeit beziehung haben so regula
riten einerseits oder auch contra
faktische abhängigkeiten contra
faktische regularien könnte man sagen
dann denken wir immer schon dass es sich
um kausalität handel und darauf hatte
einige der videos hingewiesen
er hat ja auch gesagt wir sind so
disponiert dass wir bei jedem bloßen
aufeinanderfolgen was die wisi
regelmäßigkeit hat sofort davon ausgehen
dass sich im ursache und wirkung haben
und das dürfen wir nicht und jetzt zeigt
eben jack cam noch einmal sehr deutlich
dass wir das selbst empfand der contra
faktischen analyse nicht tun dürfen weil
es eben andere formen der determination
gibt als der kausalen determination das
biologische determination und eine
begriffliche determination dies
vielleicht noch ein guter punkt wir sind
jetzt am ende die nicht nur dieser
sitzung des gesamten semesters
angekommen wir haben gerade im letzten
sitzung sehr schwere texte hier versucht
zu verdauen und wir haben damit
eigentlich am ende gesehen dieses
qualitätsproblem sperrt sie irgendwie
einem finalen verständnis das ist extrem
schwierig eine der ich weiß zusammen
eine der am meisten akzeptierte ssten
theorien ist die von mackie also die
wird auch in der wissenschaftstheorie am
meisten herangezogen
natürlich neben der neurologischen
also nach neben der regular readers
these die man also ein bisschen
ökologisch verstehen kann wenn wir hier
was einsetzen dann folgt kann dass das
ist auch ein häufiger typ mir ist jetzt
nicht so bewusst dienstag ein experte
ich glaube david knowles kausal analyse
findet in der wissenschaftstheorie nicht
so viel verwendung meines wissens also
es wird die regular rietz theorie dann
haben wir ein großes fass aufgemacht mit
dieser notwendigkeit relation da hat uns
wie schon sagte der mecki viel geholfen
dass wir einfach dieses anteils cds noch
mal genauer analysieren müssen und
bestimmte faktoren die eben anders
gewichtet sind
dann haben wir gesehen dass es das
problem der wahrheit gibt dass wir uns
fragen müssen ja wie weit ist jetzt die
situation wo hören wir auf und das sie
hatten gemeint das hat was mit werten zu
tun ich glaube dass die legen da
durchaus richtig aber eben das muss
jetzt nicht unbedingt so eine
willkürliche wertungs science und ich
habe eben so ein bisschen die intuition
ohne sie jetzt genauer aus buchstabieren
zu können dass qualität eben auch ein
gewisser normativer begriff ist was
jetzt nicht heißt dass er eben
willkürlich ist aber wenn wir eben sagen
'das war kausal relevant dann machen wir
eine sehr starke aussage wir könnten es
auch nur schwächer verstehen es ist in
einem determination zusammenhang der
contra faktische analyse das reicht auch
um kontakte zu analysieren aber es ist
nicht so stark wie kausalität als ich
glaube dass eben im kausal begriff
normativität ins spiel kommt diese frage
wie man diese normativität zu
analysieren hat ist eine ganz schwierige
frage weil mit der contra faktischen
analyse hat david luiz jetzt wenn wir
jack kim ernst nehmen noch nichts
essenzielles oder absolut
definitorischen über die qualitäts
redaktion ist hat nur was gesagt eben
über contra faktische beziehungen
dann wäre der fall ob die sogar das
gesamte beispiel nicht einfach alles
abdeckt dann nicht noch ein bisschen was
fehlt in kausalität zu bestimmen und ich
glaube und das wird mir wieder ganz zu
beginn dieses seminar ist wir haben so
die intuition das konzert etwas mit
einer gewissen kraft zu tun hat denken
sie zurück als sie uns gefragt haben was
sind die enten der der regatta an der
kausalität relation und manche sagten
kann zum beispiel ein bisschen
substanzen und es sind kräfte kräfte
wurden auch für immer verwendeten ich
glaube dass wie einfach es nicht
schaffen oder große probleme haben diese
kraft die da irgendwie wirkt die
begrifflich zu fassen das ist ein
riesenproblem die sehkraft wirklich
begrifflich zu modellieren weil wir sie
in einer bestimmten form von
wirklichkeit zu tun haben das ist so
meine letzte intuition oder dass das
ausgegoren wäre
sie haben jetzt jedenfalls einen großen
breiten überblick bekommen sie bekommen
von mir die zusammenfassung der heutigen
sitzung zusammen mit allem weiteren
bereits erfolgten gesamt fassung
gebündelt zu einem kleinen buch einen
kleinen heftchen und dann bin ich
gespannt auf ihre hausarbeiten wenn ich
die auch noch gelesen habe dann bleibe
ich sie und machte daraus ein eigenes
buch